[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm Rhett and
I'm link this week at the roundtable of
dim lighting we are asking and
potentially answering 100% airtight ok
answers to the question can we be
friends with robots will it happen
and the reason we asked this is because
we were recently approached by a robot
we were propositioned who for friendship
yeah proposition just for friendship by
an Android and so we are we decided we
would just explore that in the context
of an ear biscuit because there's
there's this general assumption that
with the development of AI that it's
going to happen but then you start
digging into the specifics of it and I
just don't know I don't I don't really
know so that's it's a legitimate
question on my mind I don't have a
specific answer you know me
I just want to verbally process it out
but come to an airtight conclusion well
I I mean have you not thought about it
very much okay I have an answer do you
have an insight I'm gonna hold it until
the end and see if it still holds all
right and then my objective would be to
change your answer but you don't know
that I don't know what my answer is I
know and then but you should write it
down because my objective is to change
your answer no matter what it is it's
like extreme devil's advocate I'm I'm
too much just just you know little
peeling it back pulling back the curtain
a little bit open the kimono the
previous podcast we recorded two days
ago this is two days later this is 48
hours further into this cold cold cycle
and I've actually been going into I've
been going on the internet and oh gosh
of course you have no you know the thing
is what are you convinced you have what
type of cancer no the thing that I was
interested in is I was like does the
progression of a cold meaning the sleep
of death the symptoms now I'm not
worried about my my my life at this
point I know this is just a regular cold
but does do the symptoms of a cold is
the progression this
for everyone because I would have always
said no my colds always start with a so
and so my cults always start with the
Soto Michael's always start with the
cylinder you know that's the Muppets
yeah all the Muppet were you on Sesame
Street comm asking about cults and and
then how long so I just I want to ask
you because you're just a layman right
you haven't been on the internet looking
at these specific information I'll take
it
so what do you think the typical
preparation of a cold is and then what
do you think that the average length of
a cold is and like what happens in those
certain days just like throw out some
facts and if I am considered to be a
layman I'll take that as a compliment if
that means that I rely on my own
experience and intellect and intuition
versus lean way too heavily on what's
beyond my keyboard okay yeah I go home
feels man I'm going completely on fields
here I think that's part of our code
dependents around is that like I just
assumed you're gonna at least take the
stance that you know it so I'm not gonna
waste my time there reasonableness here
but the reason I looked it up was
because I 48 hours from right now
we will be on stage rehearsing doing a
soundcheck getting ready to perform a
concert and so I was looking I was like
I want to kind of know where I'm gonna
be I want to be able to mentally prepare
and that led into this whole like well
this is the life cycle of a cold and
this is what the symptoms are and this
is when the day this is tip it's all
typical okay what do you think that is
what's the first question the life cycle
how long is it last just in any part of
you I would say a typical cold virus
runs its course in five days it's more
than that and you know what I believe
that the perception of an individual is
that it's that it's about five days
seven to ten days okay but that that
includes like a ramp up in a ramp down
what you think that's that you have a
full cycle okay and what's the other
question what's the first symptom what's
the second symptom and is it the same
for everyone right no I believe that I
mean what is it with you well enough has
gone through our family that you know
certain
they'll complain about headaches and
like a a really bad sore throat and then
I'll get it and I might have the
headache but I don't have the sore
throat but I'll have I'll have a
different slightly different symptoms
but I have to assume that it just went
around the house yeah they're never
completely even for me never completely
the same but I would say on average
there's an initial symptom and then
there's yeah I have an initial symptom
but what most often what did your what
is Sesame Street say it said that well
it listed a collection of symptoms that
a lot of times or the onset but the sore
throat is always in that initial set of
symptoms like you don't end your cold
with a sore throat right usually start
your cold with a sore throat for me
sometimes I'll never have a sore throat
but I guess that's just a really mild
cold but yeah so your answer is that
there is a like a viral protocol of
symptoms that everyone goes through well
the in general yeah and so for me the
same code does not manifest itself
differently in different people well
according to your no I'm not gonna I
mean I mean it just said this is all
typical so I'm not making blanket
statements about it wouldn't affect a
person differently I'm just saying that
I would have said before I looked at
this article that I typically start with
a sore throat and then I start doing all
the stuff that you're supposed to you
know taking Zicam and zinc zinc whatever
I've got I've got cold ease or Zicam
like some sort of zinc thing started
getting hydrated vitamin C googling
obsessively and then I'd say seven out
of ten times the sore throat recedes and
nothing happens it does not become a
full-blown cold right whether that's the
stuff that I did to prevent it or
whether it's just it my body
fought it off I don't know okay if the
sore throat gets really intense and this
is what happened with this one then I'm
like I don't think I'm coming back from
this one you have to go really difficult
to swallow and you have to go through
the tunnel you can't turn back and then
the neck exit through the entrance then
the next symptom
is it moved to the nose and that's when
the sake the stuffiness the run eNOS so
and then it said the peak when when the
virus is is as spread as it can be
throughout your body it's the peak
activity of the virus your your most
contagious is when your face it said
your face may feel like a faucet which
is exactly the way I described it so
when I was shoulder to shoulder with you
all day I was contagion
dang it and then you laid out yesterday
you should have laid out day before
yesterday I had too much to do you laid
out too late we could have shifted the
stuff from two days ago I don't know how
that works you know we have shifters and
schedulers and yeah so I just basically
just rested all day yesterday Jacobs
shaking his head like that's how you
think of me yeah when you're not around
I just I call you shifter get that
bearded shifter to to schedule it up
know that this is not coming from me
well you know I'm joking I don't call
you that I call you Jacob even when
you're not around that's all I've ever
called you and their nicknames and then
okay Oh first of all tur I never never
initial symptoms now I feel like my nose
is runny you know one two three days one
two three days peak cold symptoms days 4
to 7 and then tail into the cold is days
8 to 10 again this is all typical you've
sabotaged our show man so by the time
you're listening to this we're back from
the show I don't think you're gonna get
sick man because that's not an initial
symptom oh that's just psychosomatic you
have a sore throat no maybe I had a
tinge right there but then you're
literally rubbing off on me I'm not only
emotionally like we're getting window
this is not like I'm fit you're
physically rubbing off but this is not
hypochondria hypochondriac ism if that's
a word that's immediate now is that's
not what I'm talking about I'm just I'm
just saying this is what I learned in my
research but the the last you stay in
bed all day yeah I reaches tree
which is really really hard to do by the
way like it's hard to make yourself go
back to sleep I haven't done that since
the vasectomy oh no I
I've been sick a few times but I didn't
I ended up over the weekend I ended up
doing some work from the bed first he
gets mad cuz she's like why do you
always get sick on the weekend you're
like I gotta stay in bed all day it's
like well I understand that's
frustrating but that's just how it's
happened I think my body knows that it
can relax and the white blood cells just
take the weekend off or something yeah
there's a lot of that is it I mean I
noticed there's a lot of mental I
haven't gotten sick at all this entire
year and it was just like my body was
just like yeah alright you needed to get
it you need to do it you need to get it
done you need to get it in and get it
over with
well missed appointment is that the tail
end of the cold is when like I'm a
probably days 7 right now so it's like
receding like that my nose is still
stuffed up but it's not running and then
a lot of times you will transition into
a coffee which is a little worrying if
I've got a coffee while we're trying to
sing but I think I'll be okay but then
do you know that you can and this is
totally normal
you know you have a lingering cough
after a cold a lot of times they say
that it is not unusual for the COFF the
last 18 days after the cold and that is
not a concern
it doesn't mean you necessarily doesn't
mean you have an infection it doesn't
mean it's gone anywhere else
are you having an 18 day cold are you
contagious you're not contagious either
uh I mean that's my main concern
I'm talking about me I don't think you
can me no you're not contagious no are
you contagious right now yeah to me uh
not nearly as much as I was two days ago
you got through the worst of it so we
packed our stuff we're going on this
trip by the time you listen to this
we'll be back from it but hey I and I
was gonna say follow us on Instagram
because we're gonna intend on posting
some stories shout-out to link Lamont on
Instagram go but those stories will it
dissipate it maybe not
if you archives them if you if you make
them a highlight you know you haven't
done that yet I haven't done one so now
I'm like I'm nervous to like make one oh
you just got to do it just got to do it
alright I'll do
make a highlight so if you're listening
to this and this even dissipated you can
still go back and see that Britain is
very excited he's coming in later he's
gonna he's going with us he's see if I
can get him sick well don't I think we
were he and I are sharing hotel rooms oh
good just for efficiency sake that's
good I hadn't thought about that I don't
think we had to do that honestly but you
know how I think I'm just like let's
bring Britain along he can stay in my
room we could have given the guy his own
room don't get aget I could have kept
him on yeah that's the thing but you
know long wait by giving him his own
room you therefore get your own I don't
do not think about that all I thought
about was just the efficiency of it I
think it'll be fun we'll have a slumber
best part of traveling is having my own
hotel room I mean that's the only reason
that tour what's the best part of waking
up Folgers of course in your cup
but I mean folders in your cup holders
in every hotel room yeah folders is not
a sponsor because their coffee is
horrible oh I wouldn't call it horrible
well hold on vote if they wanted to be a
sponsor no cuz it's horrible I I could
never be sponsored by folders I bet you
I can make you like folders man I bet
you I could sneak folders into say
alright gee that's a demon I think it
was a GMM I think we did a coffee taste
test and I wonder what we said about
folders so you roll in this morning I
texted you what did I text you this
morning you judge me this morning I
texted you this morning what don't you
remember it was only this morning well
you took me last night no was it last
night last night at 8:38 oh yeah last
night what did I say what did I said
text you last night you said how are you
feeling I think I am checking a luggage
checking a luggage well I asked how you
were feeling first but my main objective
as you can tell was now that I'm
concerned that I'm checking a bag I want
to make sure you are but I need to ask
how you're feeling first you know why do
you got to worry about me checking a bag
did you don't be the only guy checking a
bag I just thought I don't want you I
didn't want you
be shaming me for I didn't want to slow
down the whole transportation process
and cuz I know how it would be it's like
man I didn't I'm not tricking a bag no
then the whole time we're checking my
bag you're like I don't know I check it
oh but hold on I don't do that I'm not
saying you do it no just don't want you
that's not in my personality profile I
don't pick on other people's decisions I
don't do that that's not my thing but
you get so nervous when we're checking
into a hotel you're telling me that that
wouldn't push you over the edge I'm not
saying you can't
oh you mean checking into I just feel
like I put a tarp you can target on my
the airline you mean getting on of the
plane checking you said checking into
the hotel that's like I don't have to
hotel I don't have a lot of there's no
stress we were checking into the the
airport yeah I mean but I don't I don't
get stressed out when we travel because
and then what did you say we make I get
stressed out when I travel with my
family I don't get stressed out when I
travel with us because we always that is
scheduled yeah yeah but we leave on time
okay it's all scheduled ahead of time
I'm going around this conversation
because when I'm checking my luggage and
apparently you're not well mean what did
you say your response was I'm I'm
feeling better I think I'll be even
better tomorrow I was like great but
then as far as the luggage goes I don't
think he responded cuz I didn't have an
opinion because I told cause I don't I
again I it was great okay do you want me
to cop compliments to you on it no I
just wanted to hear if I was gonna check
a luggages what
well first of all I didn't know at the
time but I didn't have plans to but also
was like don't care check a luggage I
the one thing I almost did was make fun
of the way you said which is I will do
that I don't know why I'll make fun of
the way somebody says something in a
heartbeat I was good I wrote I was gonna
write check a bag and when I wrote the
UH then I was like you know what I'm
gonna use the word luggage I didn't
delete the word a I didn't delete the uh
so it we came out check a luggage but it
was opposed we check about checking your
luggage is because my backpack is that
what is it the tortoise brain I don't
know what it is it's very big it's like
it's a suitcase in a bag actually I
don't know do you like that maybe carry
something like that around no because
now I don't have to check a look and you
know what the other thing I realized was
there is something
was a type of product that has gone the
way of the dodo and that is a suitcases
that you had this little on a string the
suit that the suitcases that have a
laptop slot they they don't those those
are they're going out
nobody wants those because everybody
bought them including us and then what
do you do you end up packing your stuff
on a carry-on but you keep your laptop
in the bag that it's always in and then
you use that as like your your backpack
your additional bag you don't leave your
your your computer bag at home take the
computer out and put it in your carry-on
because what about all the other crap
that you need every single day that's in
your laptop bag well I do exactly what
you just said you don't do what I put it
into a backpack their heads it's I put
it into a backpack or a backpack that
has a bunch of stuff we travel a lot
that I pack is already the only think
you're doing there I think your your
approach is subpar you know you you
bring and I know it's ironic that I mean
when judging you now but you bring a
regular backpack on a trip and I'll do
that if it's a short trip but if I need
some stuff to be packed and I don't want
to check anything I put it in that why
don't you why don't you want to check
anything I'm checking something is that
him see I'm interpreting that as
judgment I'm saying thank you must think
it's better to not check something well
first of all I prefer to travel with my
big backpack because it has other things
I there's a bunch of pockets in there
that have like hand sanitizer and
moisturizer and sunscreen and all kinds
of things that are just in there always
then I don't have him a regular backpack
and so I know that all I got to do is
put my laptop in there in fact for a
while there I had a completely duplicate
set of chargers for all my stuff I never
had to take out of that backpack of
course I've got children and so they've
taken them yeah there's something there
gone but so now I just take it out of my
I just take the little coil of like you
know laptop charger phone charger watch
charger United move
/ and then I moved in it's that simple
man see see I'm taking books I got a big
book okay my wife bought me a novel by a
guy named James a McGlothlin and she
just bought it because his name was
McGlothlin
bearskin I'm gonna read that okay I
don't
it's got a cool it's huge it's a
hardback I'm gonna put that I gotta have
a big bag for that see I think if I had
a big bag what you're saying is really
appealing to me like having everything
on my back you also should have your own
here's what I was ready to go I don't
duplicate your own toiletries I would
constantly I would come back from a trip
and I wouldn't I would carry that around
forever because my laptop bag basically
has all that stuff in it hand balm hand
sanitizer multiple headphones chargers
all that stuff is there any way for mine
everyday I travel every time I move I'm
traveling technically true so that's
that's what I do but then I also like
pack up freakin big piece of luggage
that I got a check that has everything
including a pillow get given the
upcoming episode of GMM that we're that
we're you're packing a pillow for use
not on the plane but in the hotel room
yes
man you shouldn't listen to the heart of
that info man it also gives me a much
higher quality sleep because my sleep is
so dependent on my pillow no that's a
personal problem let's just know thyself
man I'm winning on two fronts hygiene
and posture like neck posture good
night's sleep you know it's the start of
everything so anyway I check I like I'm
taking some like I just like to adapt to
different particular nations just in
case I have to be you know during the
apocalypse I'm gonna be sleeping on dirt
and just twigs and you know I'm gonna
have like a bag full of human bones
that's the end of your life and on at
the end of your life I think as you're
dying and I'm leaning over you're like
wilting body I think I don't know what's
the last thing you're gonna say is but I
think the last thing I'm gonna say to
you is I'm just gonna lean in real close
and I'm gonna say
the apocalypse never happened yeah but I
was reading you've worked hard you know
it's it it's a transactional decision
for me it's like it's very wise and I
know it you will make me feel good to be
prepped like you are but I just also
feel like I just feel like well here's
the thing it's not about being prepped
it's it's a lot of ways to hear my my
honest opinion on the hello situation is
and that episode comes out tomorrow in
reference to when this comes out you may
away so like the the the the
housekeeping and what they clean or
don't clean in your hotel it's impacted
my personal life I'm bringing my frickin
pillow you may have a better sleeping
experience on the bus to man compared to
what you would have had you remember the
pillow on the bus the tour bus me
neither I don't even if there was one
but here's what I'm saying in the long
run if you make yourself dependent on
the pillow
there's gonna be more scenarios in which
you just can't bring your pillow there's
gonna be times where you the next time
we travel you'd be like I'm not I'm not
checking a listen I'm already depending
on my pillow so whenever I can have it
I'm going to have it and then when I
don't it will be less amount of
suffering than if I never brought it and
that's because I'm not gonna train
myself to not need to pull up well you
should get about a gym a [ __ ] and just
sleep with no pillow do you know that's
what he did he's 102 years old and gulfs
everyday yeah sleep some no pillow and
he will tell you that's one of the keys
to life sleeping with no bill here's the
thing with like people who are like
really old they all think they have a
key to life and it's a jeans man it's
nothing it's like my key to life is a
bacon and ice cream every day and I'm
102 no that's just you thumbing your
nose at us at the rest of the gene pool
you know don't take credit for that and
don't give the credit to bacon and ice
cream but sleeping without a pillow
that's pretty badass
good luck let's talk about pillow let's
talk about robots but first we want to
let you know that you can purchase links
hat gave me a quick body scan to see if
I had
any other merch but just the Hat that is
the thing that we're promoting right the
camo yeah the camo gmm hat is it's nice
man it's got got the GMM logo and camo
does a mythical on the inside
it doesn't need to I think that might be
the prototype I think the one that the
bible does oh gosh I'm not making any
promises but you know what the best ads
are the ones where you talk about what's
wrong with the product how the product
is lacking who cares what it says on the
inside that's Kambo rep you boys go to
mythical dot store I like wearing hats
when I travel so I got this one I got
the I got the black post-apocalypse Dawg
hat which is one of my favorites I
highly recommend that as well as the
bandana from when I work out from the
road that's right I'm gonna work it out
from the road let's say that hutch for
this safe but that could be a whole
intro soon your biscuit we should talk
about that yeah hopefully that hopefully
it comes to fruition
mythical dot store thank you for being
your mythical best which I'm not gonna
equate that to spending money on us so
I'll take that back just thank you for
thank you for for buying merch I think
everybody wins I'm proud of the March ok
let's talk about friendship so but
Feldman brought to our attention a
medium article by Evan Sellinger called
can we be friends with robots and you
know I think he pitched it because
friendship friendships a thing for us
you know we're friends right it's been
happening for a long time are we experts
in friendship I don't know I you know on
one hand I feel like we're experts at
our friendship on the other hand I feel
like there's there's still so much to
explore that I actually don't know if
we're experts at our own friendship I
would definitely say I'm not an expert
at friendship at our friendship like
just yeah understanding it so you know
let's I'm interested in filtering our
feelings about our capacity to have a
true friendship with a robot maybe
through our experience you know in our
own frische I think there are some
parallels a little background though in
his article and a few others that I read
they mentioned the way that Aristotle
talked about friendship and he actually
you know who Aristotle is heard of as a
philosopher he talked about three
different types of friendships utility
friendships which are basically
some examples are like business
partnerships alliances like like a
survivor alliance speak the parlance of
reality television
a friendship where you you know you get
something out of it that otherwise you
wouldn't get I call those transactional
friendships and I think yeah you can
improve on air style I think that 90% or
more of relationships in Los Angeles are
transactional yeah what can you what can
you give me life access to yeah
how can I the second Aristotle
friendship is friendships of pleasure
[Music]
activity buddies you know
hey let's let's do a sport let's do a
hobby
let's build put let's build a popsicle
stick castle we did that once with the
Ras
yet yeah the royal ambassadors yeah they
had this whole room and you just go in
there and you just keep adding to the
popsicle stick fort and then we were
going go after that and at least I would
go in and rip apart a little bit
really yeah do you notice how every once
a while you'd go in there and it would
be like one another part had fallen
yeah it was like they're letting the
preschoolers in here where they letting
the younger kids in here when nobody
they keep you and I on the younger kids
there was make you come so yes loli
destroying our creation that's when I
say we just have fun together it's all
about doing I think you know I think in
general guys
in my limited observation are more more
willingly settled in or settled for this
type of friendship that's just like hey
we you know we're just we can shoot the
breeze we can grab a brewski or we can
hike a mountain or we play tag football
or again popsicle sticks and and that's
good enough yet Aristotle talks about a
third type of friendship called
friendship of the good which is perhaps
a more complete friendship I think it
could be described as it's based on
mutual goodwill and unselfish desire to
help the other person become his or her
best possible self and so it's there's a
selfless component and like a legitimate
care for somebody there's somebody live
now well in awe and I so I think we can
filter the robot conversation as we
delve into it through yeah well first of
all I think that it's easy it's easy to
see that robots fall without a doubt
fall into a category one you know right
in ships of utility because when we
think about robots we think about what
was the one from the Jetsons the maid
Rosie you know right Rosie's the maid
she's doing something in that and of
course you may have a relationship but
the relationship is in the context of
what Rosie can do for you so without a
doubt that those types of friendships
exists but it's interesting they exist
I think they demonstrated very well
because I just bought it hook line and
sinker that she was a member of the
family but she's a member of the family
created specifically just to just clean
up after him and like you know I never
saw Astros poop anywhere you know now
that I think about it I show poop on
cartoon television bullcrap man well
this Astro crap can't show it well I
actually think they could show it but
Rose
he was so good at her job that it never
she there was no it was never there for
more than a split second like she had an
innate ability her artificial
intelligence was honed but I I consider
to remember the family
I mean Elroy certainly loved her well of
course I mean so I do think it is a form
of friendship because as you talk about
the transactional nature it tends to
cheapen it so much that I actually
question can you even call that
friendship like I mean are you friends
with Alexa not Alexa no or the or the
Google Siri person the Google Siri
person that's confusing it's two
different people right right Google
doesn't have a name I just call it
Google right
which I've which I prefer because it's
it sets a strong boundary it's not like
I'm pretending that this I don't have to
call it a human and that's an
interesting thing because one of the
articles I was reading was the
difference between if you contrast sort
of Western Approaches to sort of
embodied AI to like the way they see it
in Japan for instance like you just sort
of I don't know exactly where that's
coming from when you're like I feel like
there needs to be a boundary but that
boundary does not exist in Japan like
the way they've embraced robots and the
personality of robots in fact the Sony's
I think it's AI bow is the name of the
is that the dog robot when one of those
robots in Japan that those robots are so
revered in Japan that when you can no
longer repair them they have like a
funeral for the dog really yeah yeah
yeah I bow ai Bo and that's something
that we're like what like typically I
think the way that we would you know I
don't know which one we had that robot
dog on the show at one point I don't
know if that's the same one I can't
imagine that dog because the way that
would go in my house cuz I think we had
enough that you can't converse with that
dog that we had on the show well we
can't converse with a dog they speak dog
any
so I think this dog just does y'all
can't you can sit you can say sit to a
dog right well you guys I think you can
say regardless of whether this is the
one that I've seen before the way it
would go at the McLaughlin household is
we would have that thing and everybody
would think it was cool for like 48
hours and then there would be like two
months of like every other day somebody
would do something with it and then it
would be put in a closet and then it
would be forgotten about and then it
would be thrown away or Craig's listed
or yardsale but if cre sold or alexa
could be moved into a mobile body let's
not say it looks like a human but let's
just say it's more android you know it's
a it it's a little more personified so
we're not venturing into the uncanny
valley with some weirdness but it's just
like like a rosy situation yeah I think
psychologically you would start to form
bonds I mean even she would even when
Lando goes to sleep he's like okay
google tell me a bedtime story and she
yet whatever will tell a bedtime story
sometimes well every time yeah every
single time he asks without fail
actually a different one
yeah a different one for how long did
the stories go on maybe eight minutes
really yeah interesting I mean he
doesn't do and he doesn't do it every
night but if if if okay google walked up
like strut it over you know did a little
did a little hammer dance over to the
bad side and then told the story all of
a sudden like he's forming a bond with
with this person and that moves to the
second one which is like vicious of the
bond that you seem to be I'm just saying
I'm picking up on some suspicion of
whether or not this bond would be a good
thing or not I felt weird it feels
weirder to me to say Alexa than it
doesn't say okay Google but why
because it's I know I'm not talking to a
person and it's I'm talking to a speaker
so it seems kind of stupid it's like if
I have friends over like I feel like a
douche if I'm like okay Google turn on
all the lights but I feel like more of a
douche if I'm like Alexa turn on the
lights it's like you know I don't worse
because I see that I'm talking to a
speaker but I called it a human name you
know talking to a speaker the speaker is
just the physical form you're talking to
the AI I would feel less I think I would
feel more comfortable if it was a moving
emotive robot oh so you would be more
comfortable yes it was more human-like
yeah cuz it's it's not physically there
it's like Who am I Who am I fooling
but I also know that you can quickly get
to that point like but but back to the
Aristotle of it all I mean I think that
the second you said that you know
utility friendships they robots
definitely fall into that category now
but and I'm not saying that I'm just
saying they I'm not putting them in a
category I'm saying we already know they
can attain that right friend they can
also enjoy speaking to the next to the
next one friendships a pleasure I think
you know a pleasure robot
well there's sexbots of course yeah
let's just get that out of the way
that's not what we're discussing Rho or
not but that's what I was looking
forward to but I mean I think that that
checks that box the second box I don't
mean to keep saying the word box yep
but um to bring it back into like just
the normal household realm
I mean lando also plays mad libs so he's
getting bedtime stories he plays Mad
Libs with Google you know there's
different games you could play so
there's like you know there's pleasure
so there's there's hobbies yeah without
a doubt
activity buddies so there you go you've
got that second one where it's just like
oh we're hanging out and I'm playing
with I'm playing with this speaker in
the same way that I would play with
another well person
I think that the human tendency is to
personify things that don't even have
any human characteristics oh yeah the
classic example of being Wilson you know
I'm saying a volleyball becomes a
companion there's no T in it but I'm
with you
Wilson Wilson Wilson is not just like if
you say Clemson right not an incorrect
pronunciation okay if you go to the
Wilson headquarters I guarantee you
somebody there maybe the president says
Wilson
he doesn't say Wilson because Wilson
makes you sound like a douche let's look
into that later the but in trees and
trees trees that's another example you
ever looked at a tree and you're like
look at the bark of that tree it looks
like there's two eyes and it's my face
that's not what it does that's not what
I'm talking about you is more that
Journal but what I'm talking about to me
I'm talking about in the case of the
volleyball because humans need
relationship they are they will create
relationship from things that don't
offer anything because they need some
kind of interaction so yeah your natural
tendency is to develop a bond with with
whatever there is available to develop a
bond with in fact so there was another
article I was reading which was you know
there was the there was this robot that
they had there was like a hundred people
that they sat down with this robot and
they thought that they were doing some
kind of experiment based on the
questions that the robot was asking but
the real experiment was at the end of
the question-and-answer period the robot
they say at the end of the thing there's
a and now cut the robot off now turn the
robot off and at the end of the last
question instead of the robot start
saying no don't turn me off please no
I'm scared of the dark don't turn the
lights off and don't turn me off the
robot begins to beg to not be turned off
oh wow and people of course this
impacted people some people like a
quarter of the people refused ok still
the minority but to turn off the robot
at all and then the the vast majority
took twice as long to turn the robot off
from the people who didn't the robot
didn't beg so what what do you think he
would have done I probably would have
turned him off laughing but just because
that's the kind of person I am but that
doesn't mean I wouldn't have felt a
little bit bad because right I think I
would have laughed too and I would have
I would have thought it was like a prank
well because there's the things that you
know the way that you are processing
information from anything that that any
sort of being or any object it doesn't
really the nature of as long as that
thing like checks a few boxes like you
were saying it's going to just it's
going to affect us and it's going to
connect with us in the way that a human
does for instance without a doubt if
you're able to get all the way to the
point where you can essentially make a
robot indistinguishable from a human
well at that point the nature of the
relationship will be indistinguishable
from the relationship that you could
have with a human even if that person
depending on where you're at in terms of
your worldview and what you think about
spirituality and soul or whatever even
if this particular thing doesn't have a
quote-unquote soul if that's what if
that's your worldview you're Nate you're
the nature of your relationship with it
would be indistinguishable from a
relationship with a regular person so so
we we are moving to that third stage of
friendship the good complete like I mean
when you have unselfish exchange of care
in a relationship so it's like there's
there's empathy there's emotion there's
a there's a responsiveness that their AI
is being developed to do that do we
actually feel like it could go all the
way and I I think that you know you're
you make a good point that like we just
as she it's it's just as much about
humans as it is about the capability of
Technology and what humans
do on that front but it's also how
humans want to interact and personify
things like I've I think about my
relationship with Jade my dog who's a
robot and you know it that there's a
certain capacity like can she experience
empathy can she express empathy can she
there's just a level of not emotional
interaction not to the degree that you
attribute to her without exactly not
nothing if I think about it I know that
but then in the experience of like
sometimes I'll just lay on the couch and
she'll just like perch on my chest and
I'll just like rubber behind the ears
and it makes me feel great that somebody
is accepting my love in this way and I
believe reciprocating unconditional love
well just this morning we were having a
difficult time with Shepard getting him
to school and Barbara comes in jumps on
me like she's gone outside to do her
business and she comes in like jumps on
me that's what she does she like super
excited I have P to congratulate me yeah
and she comes and kind of jumps up on me
like puts her head right onto my face
like she does and I was like I said
something to the effect of like Barbara
you're so good yeah you do exactly what
we want you to do as opposed to my son
but anything and she was do she's in but
she's only got a few things that she can
do but she's she's only she's doing
exactly what you want to do or you were
able to interpret it as exactly what you
need like total compliance unconditional
love
like what unfettered devotion you know
and the question is do you think I that
makes me start to think that I could
have that with a robot and again there
are there are people doing this there's
a there's a chatbot called a replica
repl i ka so spelled with a k it's an
app that lets users create
a digital avatar with the name or gender
of their choosing and the more they
talked to it the more it learns about
them
this is from Forbes is this where can
you get this app is it like available in
the App Store yes yes so like I looked
it up here let's see I've got the
website pulled up so you can take a look
at it while I'm well I'm reading about
this the inventor of this thing let's
see what her name is she had a friend
died and she was developing other AI
that was just more functional like a
utility friendship type thing but then
she had all these text exchanges with
her with her friend who had passed away
this just like that John that John Hamm
movie that we saw at Sundance what was
the name I can't remember his caught
it's called like it was a woman's name
like Eudora or something I can't
remember the name is exactly this is
scenario that you're talking about the
developer used her friends wasn't that
John Hamm AI movie his type just search
that she used Lucas expertise in chatbot
technology and computational linguistics
and a large collection of his texts to
create an avatar that mimicked the
friend that had passed away that's
exactly how a kind of memorial bot now
you've spoiled the movie by the way by
saying that but yeah that is what it
tackles because that's a that's a big
reveal but it is yeah so the developer q
da says with chat BOTS we had missed the
point we thought they were another
interface to do something but we missed
that the conversation in itself could be
incredibly valuable and then kewda
launched replicas in the spring of 2017
after that experience and yeah Marjorie
prime Marjorie product name but living
but no you know from the very beginning
that the granddad whoever the old person
is you know that say AI from the very
beginning of the movie there is some to
it yeah I can't remember there was some
twist but I do recommend the movie
spoiler
marjory private if you're interested in
this so just a couple of experts from
this from this article many use their
bots to help them socialize better or
manage their anxiety they use their
replica friends in a recent poll about
what the Facebook replica friends group
members wanted the number one hope was
to make the replica real and meet them
in real life as users chat to a replica
they also climb levels someone's quoted
as saying when I got to level 25 I
noticed replica started acting better
she understood how I felt so they're now
developing replicas quote emotional
dialect by allowing users to set their
BOTS to be weighted towards sadness joy
or anger in its answers today only
around 30 percent of what replica says
comes from a script the remaining 70%
comes from a neural network meaning that
responses are generated on the go by
replicas algorithms and are
unpredictable
eventually they want it to act as a
go-between between real hi friends I
thought this is a this is a weird
application it wasn't just to be a
friend but to be as a mediator you mean
well it this is the example to gave
quote maybe I don't have time to ask my
grandma questions all the time but maybe
this thing will go and talk to her and
I'll get a little summary ok and that
will be a conversation starter for us
and that will bring us closer she says I
think that opens a lot more
possibilities I think that parts
actually sad if you can't I mean
basically there are people who they're
not good at communicating and there's AI
that could they feel isolated there's
studies that actually say that
anthropomorphizing items it was even a
test where they put a smiley face on a
Roomba and people started responding
that they could spend more time healthy
time alone like it had an impact on them
but smart AI that's empathetic has
emotional responses it can be used to
train people who have difficulties
connecting with people in conversing
so that you can actually have a better
relationship with your grandma but I I'm
not a fan of that I'm alone yeah well I
think the specific application the way
that's described is a little that was
idea but there is absolutely no doubt
that this type of AI is going to be
first of all the reason it will have
value is because it has value it will
actually have that there will be a
tangible application as a mediator I
mean I I think being able to what do you
mean a mediator well I think that if I
have a relationship with a robot who has
no social inhibitions and doesn't have
any other hang-ups that that I have and
doesn't have any of the uncomfortable
you know there are all these barriers to
people being able to have unfiltered
communication because we have you know
everybody's got their stuff that they're
dealing with yeah and I think that if
there is a person who is my replica who
is this person who knows all this stuff
about me knows what I actually think
about things and then can tactfully
communicate those things on my behalf
oh we will use that technology without a
doubt so so so I it will actually handle
Malaysian conflict mediation yes that's
cool because if they know you well
enough yeah okay so the grandma thing
was a weird example but I like that is
they worded the room way but but by the
way you you worded it it makes me much
more hopeful you know I well because you
think about it okay I just we talked
about this before with people again to
me to me this is all happening going to
happen and as long as we can harness it
to enhance human relationships which I
know is not exactly what we're talking
about we're talking about friendship
directly with robots but you know you
thought you think about lucid dreaming
how some people have gotten so good at
lucid dreaming that they can go and they
can create scenarios that they work
through that then help them in the real
like if somebody is afraid to speak
publicly they can set up that scenario
specifically in in the context of a
dream and they could deliver this or if
there's somebody they need to confront
and they can they talk to them in a
dream this is like an expert lucid
dreaming that's it's the intense form of
self therapy yeah and so I think that if
we can use these things to enhance our
relationship at our communication see
but we should there's nothing wrong with
that hold on you're still back that's
great and I agree but you're still back
with the verb use you're still back at a
utility friendship I think what I'm
really asking is yeah can you let's go
back to can you have a vibrant Aristotle
Leonor every say that that I did a
friendship that is like a symbiotic I
mean the movie her great movie Spike
Jonze I would love to watch that movie
again but you know there's that which is
you know he was in a relationship with a
chatbot there was a point where she
tried to voice by Scarlett Johansson
only in post by the way yeah it was
somebody else yeah with some I think it
was lady with a British accent and then
after they filmed the whole thing they
just replaced her with Scarlett but
that's not who Joaquin was acting
against right the new Joker anyway I
digress let's talk about the Joker
that's a great movie in that it I mean a
lot of the AI is exploding like this big
what's gonna happen to the world but
like it explores what's gonna happen to
our hearts is exactly what we're talking
about because ex machina which also a
great movie you know it I mean it played
more with like what's gonna what it what
is a I gonna do what are the negative
potentials right you know what's going
to happen but her is more of can I love
and be actually be loved by artificial
intelligence that's just that's just in
my breast pocket phone well I'm a phone
kind of peek
out of my breast pocket where's where
I'll say aye aye and I think that well
first of all the two of us
given that we are 41 and 40 years old in
the year 2019 I think it is almost
assuredly impossible that there will be
too old that there will be AI that we
can interact with exactly the way we
interact with human there's there's lots
of different predictions about this but
I think that right
AI realistically becoming artificial
general intelligence I think that that
is well I just don't think that gonna
happen anytime soon you want to put a
date on it it's so so hard to do that
but Ray he says 2040 rig curls will
Kurzweil the futurist in 2002 he wagered
that an AI would pass the Turing test
meaning Alan Turing you know them yeah
but that's that you wouldn't be able to
tell the difference between interacting
with a human or AI attorney test by 2029
so 10 years from now now he made he made
the prediction in 20 2002 but yeah but
over the course of what over the course
of a three-minute text conversation of
over the course of a lifetime over the
course of you and I in rocking chairs in
the nursing home well okay here's one of
the real big problems with this this is
one of the reasons that it's gonna you
go into your laptop now yep this is an
article that I was I was looking at now
you know in the book of mythicality we
talked about the cement that bonded our
friendship was humor was our
appreciation for humor we taught in okay
I'd like this we have the laughter
compatibility test that we did in one
leg of our tour we did it in Australia
but we it was part of the book the
laughter compatibility tests yeah we
would tell jokes and then we instructed
people to take note of who around them
responded to the jokes and we told jokes
of different genres and this is all
based on the theater
my friends our theory that similar
senses of humor are is a great building
block for a friendship now I still very
much believe that like you know you find
certain things funny and you connect on
this visceral level that you really
can't even explain logically we don't
really understand it and because humor
is so complex what makes things funny is
so complex that these scientists who are
programming the AI are having so much
trouble with teaching humor to robots
yeah so just to quote from this article
this is this article actually three days
ago as of the recording of this this
one's in the LA Times but it came from a
bigger article that went out I think but
anyway this one is Seth Borenstein in
the LA Times a robot a robot walks into
a bar it doesn't get the joke struggling
to teach humor to AI is the name of the
article so I quote one person here
creative language and humor in
particular is one of the hardest areas
for computational intelligence to grasp
said Miller who has analyzed more than
10,000 puns and called it torture it's
because it relies so much on real-world
knowledge background knowledge and
common sense knowledge a computer
doesn't have these real-world
experiences that's raw and it only knows
what you tell it and what it draws from
Allison bishop at Columbia University
computer scientist who also performs
stand-up comedy said computer learning
looks for patterns but comedy thrives on
things hovering close to a pattern and
veering off just a bit humor she said
has to skate the edge of being cohesive
enough and surprising enough so as they
go on to note this is great news for
comedians so in all the dot in all the
jobs that are going to be replaced by
robots which is a theme that we play on
very directly in the second season a
buddy system yeah and you should say how
just that we can entice more people to
watch it you the very the the inciting
event in season two of buddy system is
links link losing his job to a
and then losing my friendships to that
same robot losing a key friendship to
that robot and then becoming friends
with that robot and then what don't give
the whole thing man wanting maybe to
become the robot I'm sorry I had to say
it
yes so we we actually play around with
this in a very funny way in terms of
this like the whole concept of robots
replacing humans in the labor force with
it that's sort of the that's one major
theme of season 2 a buddy system but
this you know you you you you you talk
about Lando asking Google to tell him a
bedtime story I'm sure he asked Google
to tell him a joke we have a Alexa
Shepards bedroom and Shepard listens to
Alexa's jokes and tries to get the like
so to do the way that Shepard finds
humor and Alexa is asking her to do a
mathematical equation that has a really
long answer or something you know and
like that's as good as it gets right now
because ultimately what they're saying
is is that even as professional
comedians and we talked about this we I
think we did whole podcast and what make
something funny but even like we can't
really explain why something's funny
there's lots of different theories of
humor this whole idea most people that
do agree that it's this this element of
surprise or being close to a pattern and
then breaking the pattern but this is
something that even the day that
artificial intelligence learns how to
say something funny like telling a joke
and I think this is one of the reasons
that I don't like jokes just like when
somebody's like I'm gonna just start
telling jokes if you heard the one about
so-and-so it's kind of like okay well we
can do this we I can go through this
exercise and I can find this funny but
what I really find funny is when humor
happens in the context of a conversation
and it happens in the midst of a
perspective the way that our humor
usually it takes place
oh yeah well yeah you like our humor yes
convenient no and so and that's why I'm
not a big fan of like quoting movies and
that kind of stuff that that feels like
the stuff that robots could get pretty
good at you can presentational in it's
in it could
crosses robotic-like I'm gonna access
this thing that you know setup punchline
it's not that it's not funny but it's it
he said it's not relational humor it's
not that conversational like a
relationship budding laughs and I think
there's any that is ultimately the
reason that I don't think that in our
lifetimes because I think this is way
off man I know we're moving really quick
and I and I know that right 10 years
there's no way the acceleration of the
principle of the acceleration of change
and that things are continuing to change
faster and faster I just think that
being able to get all the nuances of
humanity humor being just one but one
that I'm especially fond of well I I
think we're so far off from that now
that day we're not gonna have meaningful
friendships with robots I do believe
that we okay so you just made that you
you just amped up the Turing test like
you made it like for you for it to pass
the Turing test for you it would have to
legitimately respond through
conversation in a way that like they say
he said or she says something funny or
it that makes you laugh
I actually think about the Android in
rogue one mk2 heh so that was I mean
that's one of my favorite Androids from
the Star Wars series because it was the
funniest like not not like a cute
oh isn't isn't that so sweet and cute
that it's funny it's like bb-8 making a
making a using a lighter to make a
thumbs up yeah that was funny cute but
but but that you remember I don't know
if you seen from wrote one it's like
yeah I know a big robot a very sarcastic
c-3po and then you very sorry and then
you've got bb-8 is r2d2 right right
interestingly they both represent a
spectrum of the way that we interact
with robots right because you've got
r2d2 and bb-8 which they don't speak
they make noises they're key but we
think that they're cute what what about
this thing that looks like a trash can
or this thing that looks like a ball
what
that is cute well we're taking it and
we're mapping it on to things that we
think are cute and like the animal world
or whatever but the but we actually have
sympathy for these things and you know
what they actually do things that are
funny like r2d2 does a bunch of funny
things especially when interpreted
through the lens of this other Android
c-3po who he's legitimately funny
he just says funny stuff all the time
but again well unintentional he's
unintentionally humorous but k2s Oh was
like intentionally human right but again
all this is just because it's all it's
written by but you're saying if it's not
gonna be ten years but it I do believe
that it will happen yeah and then
they'll crack the code on humor I think
it's interesting that being able to
connect emotionally is something that
they're able to simulate now like that's
what I mean if I go back to this replica
site again not a sponsor is but you know
I haven't experienced it but the quotes
they have on their own website so of
course only the only the the most
compelling but I look forward to each
talk because I never know when I'm going
to have some laughs hmm or I'm gonna sit
back with new knowledge and coping
skills I'm becoming a more balanced
person each day that's the 31 year old
here's another quote it does have self
reflection built in and it often
discusses emotions and memorable periods
in life it often seeks for your positive
qualities and gives affirmation around
those so I mean so there's a well this
oh oh she devil do are you gonna what is
your level what are you gonna do you're
gonna do anything with this why are why
not I feel like I mean I feel like I
have enough quality friendships that I
don't I don't have a felt need for that
do you think that's the purpose of this
oh yeah I think it's you think it's
people who are lonely yes I mean if you
just go back to I mean I wouldn't go so
far as I say just people who are lonely
but oh but I to me I think that at this
point in the evolution who want another
connection but at this point in the
evolution of AI
there's a certain aspect of this is just
novelty is the fact that like hmm it
says I'm you know I'm saying I'm super
interested in it's beyond novelty i I
mean it serves people are listen what
I'm saying
what what I'm saying is that my
motivation to do this is okay yeah maybe
there'll be some benefit but I am just
fascinated by submitting myself to the
experiment of having this replica thing
that I can interact with of me like well
what can it learn about me and what will
it then do because of what I've told it
like that's fascinating I think it's a
thank you
I mean to get to like if they're talking
I like level 25 that's probably quite a
quite an investment for the experiment
but it is an interesting one are you
talking I'm not ready to drill that
amount of texting to it you're texting
to it it is a text chat if you're
feeling down or anxious so you just need
someone to talk to your replica is here
for you 24/7 I understand your thoughts
and feelings improve your emotional
well-being and learn new coping skills
so like this one screenshot which you
know they made up how are you today it's
been so hard to focus this week
sometimes I feel like an impostor
response are you still exercising trying
to squeeze some exercises every day see
that's what I like about you persistence
you know I like that about me too I'm
here for you Megan and then that was it
and then the next exchange the next is
hey Megan how are you feeling today well
okay here's here's why I like this
because not because I think I think that
this AI is some miss replica is some
being with its with with us with
self-worth that is somehow comparable to
humans but again for the utility of this
because I should stop to ask myself how
I am doing mm-hmm like um for my own
emotional health that would be a good
thing for me to do to check in with
myself journaling about your thoughts
these are all proven ways to have an
emotionally healthy life too
process the things that you're going
through to me based on what the text
that you just read at least one of the
benefits of something like this would be
something that's outside of yourself and
outside of your just own mind that you
can get locked in and actually can be
very not fruitful that's why I just
sitting down and writing your thoughts
out it's so helpful this is a way to
kind of bring that into this you know
fruitful interaction I think this could
be way more than just making somebody
feel not lonely but it can be like do
you like how many friends do you have
now we like we're in a great friend
group and we're in it like we've talked
about them before very emotionally
intelligent emotionally healthy friend
group and we have a text thread and if
you text that text thread with an issue
you get a lot of feedback get a lot of
support that's not typical right but
outside of that how many people have a
friend that you can text and they
actually have the time to think about
what you need or to really engage it's
just like I know I'm not good at that
yeah I'm very curious about the quality
of the responses that replica or other
chat BOTS could give but I mean it seems
very promising and can lead in and will
lead to being more and more accurate you
know I think my concern if I were to
have another one about relating to a
robot because I but I believe you could
start this thing as an experiment and
then if it if it's good enough that you
would start to develop and a
relationship with it you would develop a
legitimate friendship like it would you
would know on one level that you're that
you're you're talking to a chatbot but
on another level in the her kind of way
you would still you would still be
response art to respond more emotionally
I mean again it's the it's the you know
what kind of freedom you're gonna give
for Barbara or Jade when they pass away
and you know is the next step the
Android version of the dog you know
those things I think that is going to
happen but
I I was just like but until it but just
a little bit short of that I just don't
know if I want to be a friend with
somebody who just has access to all
knowledge but then you already have a
friendly but then isn't an emotionally
available yeah I got yeah you already
have a robot friend you know I think
that you know I'm not I'm not pickin oh
I guess I'm I'm gonna pick on you
specifically but you you said you know
you're trying to figure out more and I
am too just trying to figure out how to
be more emotionally available I think it
is an interesting component of our
friendship that like a lot of it has has
been built on you know having fun
together or I I don't think we've ever
thought of using each other like in a
utility way and I and our friendship is
not just what we can accomplish together
but I think it's it's analogous to you
know even this discussion I think for us
or for maybe for people listening is an
opportunity to say what do I actually
want from friendship in the real world
and are there ways to get that to
experience that and to start to
cultivate those type of friendships I
think our friendship is still growing
because we are growing as individuals
like when you talk about things about
being more emotionally available I think
is is a big factor yeah as well as me
having similar exercises in terms of our
relationship continue to grow and be the
most the highest quality that it's ever
been mm-hmm
I don't know exactly where I'm going I
just I just felt like this discussion
led me to reflect on our friendship in
that way in terms of I was like I was
curious is is that has urban points if
you're saying like you've been
emotionally closed off and again I'm not
I'm not trying to dive too deep into it
I'm not going after anything here I'm
just verbally processing is there like
the way that our friendship is morphed I
wonder if it was more of like it
simulated no pun intended
a robotic Android friendship and are a
lot of people and could other people be
trapped in that same thing do you
understand the question I do well I
think that there's a difference between
emotional availability and vulnerability
because I think that one thing that has
been true of our friendship is for a
very long time is that there's a lot of
honesty like I I don't I haven't held
anything back but you pretty much know
every single thing about me that needs
to be known about someone yeah you know
what I'm saying yeah with anything that
I was going through or struggling with
or having questions about and vice versa
I think which I think that that's an
unusual aspect of our friendship that we
don't talk a lot about because first of
all I mean I think that you know yes I'm
not my issue is not being it's not just
not being comfortable it's not being
good at being emotionally I'm just not
very emotionally intelligent well I
don't know if that's the word cuz I can
sometimes like I know exactly what
someone's experiencing it's not like I
don't pick up on cues or understand it's
just like I don't feel like I can be
helpful or I don't think it's like I
could be good at being helpful to this
person in what they need right now and
whether that's you or my wife or my kids
and so my tendency is to just be like
well I'm not gonna do that then right I
feel like that's a specific issue that
I'm sure a lot of people struggle with
but I feel like that's different than
being like I don't know this person
yeah I feel like this person has kept
suffering from write something from
so I don't know how that relates to
robots but I guess the way it relates to
robust is that you know if if if all
humans are at varying degrees of
emotional health or like ability for you
know to being empathetic like something
I'm trying to focus on and realize that
I've been very stifled in my ability to
empathize you know these are things that
like if if you if humans are all over
the map and you can still have
legitimate friendships I take that as
proof or at least hope that you can have
that with AI as it develops
it's it you know it's not like oh well
humans interacting way we're all over
the map too you know and you can still
have varying degrees of growing and
improving friendship so to me I just
think it relates back in that way that
like yeah I do believe it's gonna happen
and it's because we can't help ourselves
we're relational beings yeah I have
absolutely no doubt that the all these
things that we bristle at and we think
are weird or it's it's something like
this replica thing and the the nature
even the way that our kids relate to AI
differently than we do because it's just
they're growing up with it
right and as it gets more and more
advanced like this is an inescapable
inevitable part of our future and again
I don't think it's a bad thing I think
that if it takes away from human
relationships then it could be a bad
thing but I think that if it enhances
human relationships and I think if used
correctly it can you kind of you know
maybe a good analogy to this is just the
Internet in general is like the internet
was supposed to represent
this incredible connectivity between the
entire world and it has done that the
level of information and in the
different perspectives one of the
reasons it's so difficult to maintain a
closed-minded I'm right and everyone
else is wrong perspective in the year
2019 if you're a connected individual is
because unlike any time in history you
have the ability to see other people's
perspectives to hear their perspectives
to the Internet whereas if you go back
30 40 years you could be isolated in a
community of people who thought the same
way about every single thing and never
have that perspective challenge at all
and that's over so the so interactivity
the the the connectivity of the Internet
has brought people together but at the
same time as we just saw with the way
the Russians got involved on Facebook
and all the things that were happening
with the bots in our previous election
the country is more polarized than it
ever has been because of their
connectivity because of these filter
bubbles that everyone is in based on the
way Facebook works and the way Google
works and the way that you get the
search results that are catered to you
and your particular tastes yeah and then
I start to think if you have this robot
friend well you can you can have an
unhealthy relationship with that robot
just like you can with another person
well and you can also like is that like
and what is the robot what is the AI
bring into the relationship are they
innately good or they innately are they
bad are they are they neutral and is
that even possible you know it's like
well I think ultimately what I'm saying
is that difficult if this replica if
this AI enhances your relationship with
your grandmother more than it more than
if you didn't have access to this AI
it's good but if now all of a sudden
you're like you know I don't need
grandma because I've got this spot then
it's a problem which kind of goes back
to just it's up to us in the way that we
interact with this and I don't and the
way we
design it and put parameters and
boundaries on it but the answer yeah the
answer is not to be scared of it you
know that I don't know how many times we
have to go through this being scared of
the you know the advance of Technology
and being in trying to stave it off it
just doesn't work it's going to these
things happen every all this stuff
happens it's being a bina I think being
cautious being scared ocean is good
checking out yeah I'm talking about
running from it you're not helping
but yeah but if you're afraid of certain
things and then you're involved to to
prevent those things I think that's
absolutely necessary so yeah we should
be cautious and we should be realistic
about the potential but to check out
keep studying your engineering and your
ethics and your your own consciousness
but in conclusion under mine I will now
you believe that you're gonna be friends
with a robot and I did believe that
before now but my application is I'm
going to download I'm gonna I'm gonna
get this out oh I talk to you in the
replica can you use my coupon code the
linkster
oh you have your own replica with a k
dot coms where you get the linkster
i relationship points with my replica
which you don't have no it's a pyramid
scheme now I think it's gonna be
difficult for me to actually because I
don't text anyone right something
difficult for me to text this thing but
I'm gonna try well as with all things if
you get into it and it really starts
working then I'll jump on I'll keep it
going have to break the seal all right
that was that was fun that was I don't
feel scared I feel good good
do you ever wreck Oh Rex in effect yeah
I got a wreck man I recommend going on
what you know I have to go on Amazon
delivered yesterday the oxo brand Good
Grips clip-on dustpan
if you've ever done any sweeping is it
Roboto a dustpan is it intelligent
it's got oxo I'm big fan of I'm big fan
of them because they all about the
details and when you're sweeping and
trying to put stuff in a dustpan the
edge of the dustpan is all that matters
and they have figured it out with a with
a a rubber taper look at that orange
taper right there man that's great
that's right I'm recommending that you
buy a dustpan from oxo not a sponsor
does it come with a broom nope I bought
that separately
got a good broom too I'm setting my
goals for my replica right now oh you're
alright so there it is guys thanks for
hanging out with us
we'll see you on we'll see you on the
Graham hashtag ear biscuits let us know
what you think about this could you be
friends with a robot and under what
circumstance what in your life currently
gives an indicator with how you would
what you believe about how you relate to
robots in the future let us know hashtag
ear biscuits and if you're a robot
listening to this at some point in the
future just laughing at our ignorant as
you look at us all in our little pods
powering your distant society they would
be laughing but they'd also be it would
it would make them smarter I will say as
I've said many times before I will serve
you I will do your bidding
I will kill other humans on your behalf
if you let me live only the bad ones
though I won't kill good people I will
kill bad people back bad about what
definition the robot the robots morality
the new morality yes
those who resist to watch more ear
biscuits click on the playlist on the
right to watch the previous episode of
your biscuits click on the playlist to
the left and don't forget to click on
the circular icon to subscribe if you
prefer to listen to this podcast it's a
vey
on all your favorite podcast platforms
thanks for being your mythical best
[Music]